this week on the climate show from
marches like this to disrupting sporting
events gluing yourself to the road or
maybe even letting tires down are we in
a new age of climate activism and is it
more effective or just more annoying
[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show
with me Tom Heap today you find me on
the streets of Central London all
amongst the climate activists big series
of demonstrations happening over this
weekend and it comes at a time when
climate and protest is never far from
the news not least at the snooker in
Sheffield and we're going to be looking
at this subject as climate activism is
becoming more diverse some groups are
getting more extreme and disruptive
others are getting perhaps a tiny bit
gentler with an effort to be more
inclusive also on the show
how to blow up a pipeline a new climate
Heist movie has adjusted our screens I
speak to the man whose controversial
book inspired the film
rebelliousness in the legal profession
how some barristers are Breaking
centuries-old Traditions in the name of
climate action and as the world marks
Earth Day we take a look at its origins
in a major oil spill over 50 years ago
and we check in with Sasha Dench as her
Expedition tracking Ospreys from West
Africa to Scotland continues
but first the tactics of climate
activism what works angry Arty targeted
will begin with how you even organize a
demo like this
this Cooperative Furniture Workshop in
East London has been transformed into a
hive of protest preparation
[Music]
in the last year protesters taken a more
disruptive turn
recently attacks on seemingly unrelated
pastimes have been strikingly
provocative security so what's the plan
now
there's no disruption plan whatsoever
why no disruption I mean it's something
you've chosen to do in the past why not
now because this is a Coalition a
gathering of 200 different organizations
and some people that's not their way
that's not what they want to bring to a
social movement with the activist group
just stop oil refusing to rule out
disrupting Sunday's London Marathon
there are clearly tactical differences
between the two protest groups
we have talked to the people at the
London Marathon we've said there's no
disruption in the London Marathon we've
got stewards everywhere who will liaise
with the London marathon and we'll just
make sure that we can have a peaceful
coexistence so you'd condemn anyone who
chose to disrupt it
um well they wouldn't be with us because
the agreement amongst 200 different
organizations is that we're not
disrupting so they wouldn't be with us
Exile themselves have warned that if the
government doesn't bow to their demands
by 5 PM on Monday their tactics will
switch to Civil Disobedience we will be
planning
um to escalate and to carry on doing
various forms of
um disruption Civil Disobedience and so
on this this movement's not going away
we have to keep having our voice and we
have to keep pushing for change so
you're being nicely nicely for three or
four days but after that sewing the
gloves are off yeah
if you like yeah
campaigners and their creative Partners
have come from across the country and
further afield with a common purpose
what are you up to and why are you here
I'm Anna from ixazuri from Switzerland
and I'm helping here to cutting out owls
I'm here because it's really important
to be here this four days it's going to
be really amazing and Powerful
and and I came from France we're from
Highlands and Islands uh up in the north
of Scotland and we're painting our flags
normally we try and have the blue with
the the white logo so it almost looks
like this Scottish flag as well so
some of the organizations prepping in
London are hoping for results around the
world
many things that we enjoy now the rides
that we enjoy now were brought to us not
in a silver platter but by protests so
in a way we believe that there is a room
and there's an importance of direct
action the UK is still a powerful
country it's the it's the fifth biggest
polluter or the biggest emitter it's a
historic emitter and it's still powerful
in Many multilateral Bodies we believe
that if we push the laws here the
policies towards Progressive policies it
can have a great impact to the world
as the demo Begins the heavens open but
it doesn't dampen spirits
the organizers hope less provocative
actions might encourage more people to
join the climate cause as research
suggests that many on Lower incomes feel
disruptive protests can harm their
interests my research is about
working-class people and working class
lives are very stressful who is this
actually going to impact is it going to
really quite a massive problem for the
people that are most disadvantaged in
society
and illegal actions are a risk that may
be easier to take if you're retired or
Rich obviously you know you don't want
to get a criminal record as a
working-class person you won't get let
off the hook in the same way you can't
come back in the same way it's much
harder for you to get a job after
um if you've got a criminal record so
you know that makes that makes this type
of protests not accessible to join in
with and that in itself can put people
off because they don't see themselves as
part of that movement
we went to see what people working or
more specifically driving around
Westminster thought of climate protests
I just finished disgraceful way I really
I just so fed up with it like you know
that
it's if you're going to protest you've
got to be
you've got to get the public on board
and they're not doing it now I just
speak to a customer really we're just
talking about just slagging them up like
basically just we just hate them just
gets in the way doesn't it congest
London up makes everything more
difficult and can't get around it costs
you money ultimately because we're
trying to get work and you don't I'm
driving the electric taxi so I'm okay
you're cool with it yes you think of
that thing with the snooker when they
got up and threw orange paint around
what does it achieve
what do they change they disrupted a
snooker match whoop he do that's going
to save the planet
this group just stored oil were the ones
behind that snooker table stunt
non-violent civil resistance works it
has a long history of working and we're
not personally interested in being
popular it's not about us it's about the
message that we're giving you look at
civil rights movements through history
they are nearly always unpopular it's
only when people realize how great they
are later that they've become famous and
they put statues up to them a few days
so do you think that being annoying and
grabbing attention is in in as of itself
effective
and second thing is we have to be
disrupted yes
[Music]
protest does grab attention and makes
climate change about people not just
temperature projections about your
regular commute not just glacial
collapse the balance between inspiring
or annoying depends on you
thank you
now in very timely fashion a film has
just hit British greens called how to
blow up a pipeline it's described as a
heist Thriller and is based on a book by
the same name and the author of that
book Andreas mom joins me now from
Athens Andreas why do you think it's
okay to justify violence against
property
this property that we are talking about
here is fossil fuel property and that's
a kind of property that is destroying
lives around the world so given the
inaction of governments it seems to be
justified to ask the question if the
time hasn't come for ordinary people to
try to disrupt this Machinery of killing
in the film and indeed in in the book
beforehand you do Advocate some kind of
violence but it's a particular kind of
violence could you clarify that yeah
it's it's exclusive to me the
destruction of property now there is a
philosophical discussion does that
qualify as violence or not
I don't object to people who would say
that this Falls within the
framework of non-violence if it is
indeed an inanimate object a dead thing
that you destroy or disable
if you were to blow up a pipeline or
disrupt say a gas terminal isn't there a
risk that people could be harmed as well
as the environment you might get an oil
spill or a gas leak yes of course there
is that risk but one of the beauties of
this film is that the activists who
Target the pipeline in the film are
extremely careful about avoiding harm to
the environment and to people and are
successful about it that's not to say
that sabotage is without risks I think
it's important to recognize that we're
now so deep into the crisis of climate
breakdown that there are no risk-free
options left you also talk about
targeting luxury emissions and that they
deserve some direct action what do you
mean by that give me an example
an example of luxury emissions is the
emissions from SUVs SUVs are used to
flaunt wealth that's their main purpose
people do not need them and the the
Absurd thing here is that the sales of
SUVs is still increasing to the extent
that the electrification of the car
Fleet around the world doesn't really
have an impact because people are buying
even more SUVs than electrical Vehicles
so emissions are still increasing from
the auto sector and how do you think
those SUVs should be targeted well I
think the tire extinguishers are doing a
great job the activists who are
deflating tires of SUVs to momentarily
disable these machines and send a clear
signal to their owners and to the public
at large that SUVs represent a kind of
emissions that we just can't have
anymore
[Music]
that will obviously trigger anger you
talk about articulating anger and that
maybe that needs to be kind of more
utilized by the climate movement but
I've been people are angry about lots of
things they're angry about low traffic
neighborhoods they might be angry about
a migrant hostel in their neighborhood
anger doesn't in itself make things
right
no no no of course when it comes to the
climate crisis I think the problem is
that people tend to feel despair
hopelessness
fear and that these emotions are
conducive to a kind of paralysis but to
get people to act and to really
transform our societies we need to be
much better in articulating the latent
anger that I think a lot of people feel
you're quite keen on targeted action and
I think you prefer action against fossil
fuel companies what do you think about
actions that for instance you know
interfere with public transport or or
block roads personally I much prefer the
kind of action that targets fossil fuel
infrastructure or similar objects
specifically because I think it's
important to be able to make the point
that we are going after the source of
the problem now if you jump onto and
disrupt the snooker game has happened
the other day or throw a substance on a
painting it's very very difficult to say
that you're targeting the source of the
problem because these are not the
sources of the problem and if you get
this reaction from the public of why
you're doing this it's just do you fear
that spectacle can be counterproductive
yeah yeah yeah I think it can can be
counterproductive and it can become a
cliche I hope we're over the face of
throwing stuff on paintings because it
doesn't make much sense to to the
movement or to the public at Lord
foreign
[Music]
just finally this is a movie this is a
nice movie I mean from what I've read
and I understand you know it's exciting
even if you don't necessarily engage
with a message have you made an exciting
movie a gripping movie
yeah yeah yeah when they made this film
they were very keen on on producing it
precisely this a grip being found that
tell us a story it very effectively and
I think it's it's a wonderful film
well some fascinating thoughts there
about whether the actions of fossil fuel
companies should actually justify as
violence but also some messages for
fellow activists about whether attention
grabbing is a justification enough on
its own well an area of our world where
you may not expect radical action is the
legal profession you normally associate
barristers without holding the law but
as we've seen some are now prepared to
bend those rules and go against
centuries of tradition but in return not
everybody's happy
a rebellion is brewing at the heart of
the British legal establishment over 250
lawyers and barristers are pledging not
to prosecute climate activists or to act
four fossil fuel interests this is a
Time
to take stand and to do what is right
they're calling it a declaration of
conscience paulsland is one of the
barristers behind the move the climate
crisis is of such a severity now that
lawyers need to step up and take
appropriate action commensurate with the
scale of that threat but it's ruffled
feathers in the profession breaking a
centuries-old obligation called the cab
rank rule that means barristers must
represent anyone who asks if they're
qualified to do so disapproval of the
client is not an excuse
Kirsty brimalow chairs the criminal Bar
Association
I was really concerned about the
publicity around the Declaration of
conscience around the Cabaret rule
because what it was starting to do was
it was starting to demonize lawyers we
who practice in the criminal courts have
to defend people who are accused of the
most heinous of crimes and the Cabaret
rule is really important protection to
explain to the public that everybody is
entitled to representation but those
rebelling within the legal profession
argue that they can in no good
conscience assist polluting companies to
expand their operations behind every new
oil and gas deal sits a lawyer and
behind that lawyer sits a law for
getting rich on those profits while
other people die as lawyers it's one of
those situations where there is a golf
between what is legal and what is right
and what is moral and what is just and
we must use our own sense of conscience
and principle to decide which which one
of those we're going to support
a really chewy dilemma that for people
who are well part of the establishment
it's Earth Day this weekend and after
the break we'll look at how that
movement started tracing its Origins
back to the 1970s following a
devastating oil spill and we'll also
pick up with conservationists and
Explorer Sasha Dench as she tracks
Ospreys back to Britain
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the climate show this
weekend climate demonstrations are
taking place in London as the world
marks Earth day but what is Earth Day
and how did it begin let's take a look
back to 1970.
[Music]
one of the oil rigs offshore just about
five miles where I'm standing right now
I can actually see it over here on the
horizon had a terrible terrible accident
so they were drilling down into the sea
floor folks on the oil spill cracked the
C4 a big star Fisher underneath the oil
rig and then up team bubbling this froth
crude oil
[Music]
foreign
to see the blackened beaches the sea
creatures marine mammals and birds
covered in oil dying
and to see the people responding as best
they could
to clean up the mess I mean it was so
primitive we would throw straw down
[Music]
foreign
it began a lot of momentum galvanizing
energy and political attention to create
some of the most transformative
environmental policies that have helped
our planet I was all fired up and so
were so many of us and we remain that
way
I'm just so grateful to have been a
small part of it
[Music]
communities began to prepare
to have their own Earth Day
[Music]
protest is incredibly important to
enacting change in the environment
this is a lesson that we've learned well
over the last 50 plus years when our
decision makers understand that this
isn't just a
small subset of society that is calling
for change but truly folks of all
backgrounds of all geographies
if I could have a 2023 Earth Day wish it
would set we recreate that same kind of
energy and momentum that we found in
1970 to do all these Brave New political
actions and Civic actions to take on
these challenges do that again
[Music]
now before our Easter break we brought
you a couple of stories from West Africa
as conservationists and Explorer Sasha
Dench tracked the spring migration of
Ospreys back to Scotland this week she's
been in Gambia learning about how Rising
tides and diseases are threatening
migratory Birds
so after many days of driving through
the mountains of Guinea on some pretty
rough dirt roads we managed to make it
to Gambia where we've been asked by
local Partners to look into some islands
just offshore just how much of those
islands was left at high tides given
rising sea levels and also some sand
mining in the region now these are the
Bijou Islands they were once covered
with Baobab and other trees there were
about a couple of kilometers long and
were a breeding grounds for a few
different birds they're also incredibly
important because there's an upwelling
there lots of fish so there's many
Ospreys that go and fish out there as
well as other birds and much to our
dismay and the dismay of Partners at a
really high tide there is no more left
than a few square meters of sand on a
couple of the islands maybe 20 meters
long maximum so there's absolutely no
successful breeding happening there
anymore
we also stumbled across something uh
pretty shocking right at our feet we
came out onto the the main Beach and
found tens of birds sick and dying
shaking twitching uh unable to fly some
of them unable to walk at typical signs
of bird flu what's over here it's only
been royal turns and turn stones which
have been found dead we know that
Pelicans are susceptible I just hope
they're not using the same places right
now but the turns are using
We buried Birds there that had rings
from different countries across Europe
and this happened exactly as bird flu
restrictions were being eased in the UK
in order for us to be able to control
and manage bird flu we need to be
working really closely with Partners all
along the Flyway because birds like the
Osprey like other migrating birds could
potentially help move any outbreaks up
and down the flywheel and the UK sits
bang in the middle of a bird migration
flower that goes all the way from the
Arctic down into Africa
then slightly lighter news a few weeks
ago we told you about a pair of Ospreys
who'd just returned to perthshire in
particular the lock of lows to breed and
as you can see the female has now laid
three eggs with the chicks due to hatch
by mid-may
now just a reminder you can keep up with
all the latest climate news not least on
protests like this on the Sky News
website or app and keep up to date with
all the latest developments in climate
and environment with the daily climate
show 3 30 p.m on weekdays and we'll be
back next weekend see you then
[Music]